[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Charles
taugourdau merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre chaque
semaine 200 exploitations agricoles
disparaissent voici des extraits de la
lettre ouverte qui vous est adressée par
Madame Cormier agricultrice ce sont ces
mots extrêmement for empreint de cette
vérité qui dérange je cite on dénombre
un suicide d'agriculteur tous les de
jours ses filles et fils de la terre de
tous âges se donnent la mort en laissant
derrièrex famille et amis être
agriculteur aujourd'hui c'est à terme
acceptter de mourir trois fois
moralement économiquement et
physiquement et nous agricultrices dans
toute cette colère et ce désespoir nous
ne pouvons qu'assister à ce qui
s'apparente un véritable génocide nous
veuves agricultrices célibataires
agricultrices conjointes d'exploitation
et femmes d'agriculteur sommes les
témoins de ce spectacle supporter seul
le poids du stress et du travail gérer
les créanciers assister à l'impuissance
et à la col l' de nos conjoints à quel
beau métier mais lorsque vient le moment
d'expliquer à nos enfants que nous
devons vivre avec le RSA qu'il n'est
plus possible de se passer des Restos du
cœur pour pouvoir se nourrir nous qui de
par notre métier nourrissons les autres
comment trouver les mots tristesse
misère et découragement sont notre
quotidien nous ne souhaitons pas devenir
les plus riches du cimetière mais
uniquement être en capacité de vivre
dignement de notre si beau métier étant
le premier maillon de la chaîne notre
proche disparition sera le début d'une
longue agonie fin de citation Monsieur
le Premier Ministre pas de ruralité sans
agriculteur les entendez-vous dans nos
campagnes que leur répondez-vous pas à
moi à ell elles aimeraient tellement que
vous leur répondiez
vous-même bien la parole est à Monsieur
Stéphane Lefol ministre de l'Agriculture
de l'agroalimentaire et de la
forêt monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Député vous avez fait le choix de lire
une lettre pour montrer la gravité
de la situation que rencontre de
nombreux agriculteurs pensez d'abord une
chose depuis que je suis à la tête de ce
ministère et depuis longtemps puisque je
vais dépasser les 4 ans et demi j'ai
parfaitement à la fois pris la mesure de
la situation et apporter des réponses
mais monsieur le député dans ces débats
où on peut faire appel à l'émotion et on
doit être en compréhension vous ommettez
de rappeler que dans ce débat global si
la question l'agriculture est posée avec
une telle acité c'est parce que des
marchés agricoles des marchés
alimentaires et c'est pas le ministre
d'aujourd'hui qui en est responsable si
je prends la question des céréales les
marchés laissez s'il vous plaît c'est
suffisamment grave vous avez posé les
choses de manière grave donc ayez un peu
de respect pour les agricultrices
auquelles vous avez fait réponse sur ces
marchés monsieur le député lorsque les
prix baissent depuis 3040 % lorsqu'un
aléa climatique s'ajoute à la baisse de
la production lorsque des crises Sanita
GPE avière et autres sujets de FCO
s'ajoute et se cumule et où l'État doit
et le ministre être présent pour plus
d'un milliard et demi avec deux plans à
chaque fois avec le souci d'apporter des
réponses concrètes à la difficultés qui
racontent les agriculteurs on peut tous
faire ce choix de dire que il y a qu' et
on trouvera les solutions cette détresse
elle nécessite un travail de longue
haleine monsieur le député et quand j'ai
fait voter la loi sur l'avenir de
l'agriculture quand j'ai fait le choix
stratégique de mettre la performance
économique et la performance
environnemental pour faire en sorte que
les agriculteurs dégagent plus de
revenus c'est un choix d'avenir que j'ai
fait monsieur le député et quand nous
avons développer l'installation dans
l'agriculture c'est un choix d'avenir
que nous avons fait monsieur le député
merci